We all love shopping and eating out!
But ever been in a situation where you spent more than you intended to?
Probably every time!
What makes you to spend more?
Is it the offer? Or the price? Or is it something else?
Do you think your decisions are really controlled by you?
Let’s find out.
The answer to this could be the Decoy effect.
What does it mean?
It simply means change in preference between two options
when presented with a third one.
Confusing right?
Let’s make this simpler for you.
You’re in a movie theater
and you've been given two options for some delicious popcorn!
A small popcorn bucket costs 4 dollars,
and a large popcorn bucket costs 8 dollars.
Most of us want more; but as we intend to spend less,
we would choose the cheaper option.
But the company obviously wants you to buy the large popcorn bucket!
What would they do?
One option could be to give a discount for the large bucket!
But there’s an even better alternative!
They add a third option called the decoy.
They now give you an option of medium sized popcorn bucket
for 7 dollars and fifty cents!
Which one would you buy now?
Most of us would opt for the large sized bucket
as this now seems better value for money.
The decoy option that is the medium sized bucket
makes the human mind make inaccurate judgments!
Notice that the decoy is priced really close to the more expensive option,
making the more expensive option look significantly better.
It’s so skewed on purpose,
that it seems stupid, to not choose the higher-priced option!
Alright! Now, instead of pricing the medium sized bucket
for 7 dollars and fifty cents,
what if it is priced for 4 dollars and fifty cents?
Which one would you choose now?
Obviously the medium sized popcorn bucket!
Because this looks better than the small sized popcorn bucket.
Don’t you think the small sized bucket is acting as the decoy here?
Yes!
So now tell me, is the decision to choose anything here controlled by you?
Definitely not!
The visual illusion is deliberately created by the company
to alter your judgments.
Thus, you take an irrational decision from the given options.
Is the decoy effect only price related?
Absolutely not!
Let’s say you’re planning to dine out with your friends.
Your preferences are quality and ambiance over price.
Here are the choices available in your vicinity.
It is very clear from the options that your obvious choice
would be the five star restaurant.
It is just a matter of half a kilometer more than the
four star restaurant to experience your desired ambience.
So, the best option is this one!
Here, the four star restaurant acted as the decoy.
Alright, let’s say we remove the decoy here.
What would your choice of preference be now?
Well, the same five star restaurant now looks like a long distance to cover.
So in this case, we would generally settle with option one.
We saw how the decoy effect plays with our judgments in our day-to-day lives!
Can we use the decoy effect for any social cause?
Let’s say your city is planning a campaign to plant trees.
You want maximum people to participate in the campaign
and also plant more number of trees.
Can you come up with a plan using the decoy effect
to motivate people to plant trees?
This is one of the ways which we could think of!
Will this work?
Notice, that here we haven’t used money as a reward.
Can you come up with more such plans without using money as the reward?
This is your Kyu Box challenge.
Let us know your interesting answers in the comments section below.
If you have learned something great today,
share this video with your friends
and don’t forget to subscribe our channel.